make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so you guys have been asking for it
so we are finally covering the the
conclusion to heroes in crisis also FYI
Tuesday Thursday and Saturday we're
covering Dark Phoenix saga
so that we can have that out for the for
the weekend and then we jump back in to
your regularly scheduled programming
which is basically almost everything
coming out from Marvel because we have a
lot of catching up to do but um with
heroes in crisis number nine this
basically answers the question that
everybody's been asking why did Wally do
what he did how did it all unfold what's
going on right because well heroes in
crisis like we have had questions
answered but it's been kind of cloak and
dagger encounter murkiness kind of been
like half answers it was just sort of
like all right like we needed a
definitive explanation to all of this
stuff and so what this does is it
initially picks up with the arrival of
Batgirl of Booster Gold of Blue Beetle
in Harley Quinn now remember these four
have been just essentially like figuring
everything out at least trying to figure
everything up and under normal
circumstances we would assume Batman
would be the one to arrive to the
conclusion about everything but remember
Harley Quinn and Booster Gold were the
ones who were on the scene and so the
result is that they actually kind of
have an insight into what's going on
that nobody else in the Justice League
has at the same time they were believed
to have been the killers and so they
were essentially underground and so what
you had was bat woman and Blue Beetle
who basically ran upon it now of course
bat woman running up on Harley Quinn was
kind of hearing the two together even
though they've never really been like
direct enemies Harley Quinn's more of
like a Batman enemy but also kind of an
enemy of the bat family I feel like in
terms of who she comes into conflict
most its Batman that's kind of what we
expect from her character really
alongside the Joker or even by herself
when she's were when she's on a team
with Gotham City sirens but the fact
remains that with Booster Gold a Blue
Beetle again this makes sense right for
the people who have been reading DC for
a while
Booster Gold and Blue Beetle go way back
like the works you know in exceedingly
good friends and so when Booster Gold
shows up on the doorstep of Ted Kord as
his hey man I didn't do this you have to
believe me
Ted Kord response is okay then let's
figure out who did and that's kind of
why we have all these guys here and so
when Harley shows up they're immediately
met by the arrival of like poison ivy
and this is kind of a cool thing it's
actually a cool little moment here
because when it comes to to Harley Quinn
what we do see the human side of her and
the sister like she feels emotion she
cries she loves things like that it's
usually accompanied by like insanity or
some crazy set of circumstances we very
rarely ever get to see Harley Quinn just
be a tried and true person right and
it's one of the things that we tend to
forget that like at the end of the day
too
despite her her you know various
escapades with the Joker and even with
poison ivy despite her dealings with the
suicide squad and so on Polly Quinn is
still for the most part a rational
person she's crazy but she's not like
Joker crazy but she don't like off the
deep end never to return to sanity and
the funny thing about this is that
poison ivy is kind of her anchor to her
sanity right it's like the one person
that keeps her from like falling over
the edge but to have been romantically
involved they were a couple of it to the
point when like poison ivy basically
died now this is also a very big
revelation here that's really kind of
built on for the last issue for the last
couple issues and as it has kept going
by Tom King and is basically the idea
that poison ivy is essentially immortal
right like she has like what she does is
something akin to like Baltimore than
the Horcrux was right like so long as
those Horcruxes exist
Voldemort would always come back the
idea behind this is that with poison ivy
a part of herself was put into a flower
and then that plant that that flower was
planted of course by Wally West five
days after she died and what that means
is that so long as she puts in essence
of herself into some part of the green
then she can always basically reman
efest she can return now of course for
those of the guys who were coming into
this brand-new the green is is just kind
of a colloquial name for like nature
more or less insofar as like plant life
right you have the red which is animals
and then you have the rot which is the
death of all things more or less you
know like death itself to a degree like
rotting decaying that kind of a thing
but just behind this is that with poison
ivy being part of the green it means
that she's literally part of nature
right like she's on par with Swamp Thing
and so basically by establishing this
again Tom King says like so long as a
part of her essence is tapped into the
green meaning like it's in a flower or a
plant or something like that and it's
reconnected to the green reconnected to
like nature itself to the plant aspect
of this world or any other then what it
means is that she can basically
reconstitute her physical form and then
of course it seems as though she has all
of her memories intact she recalls her
leak when she knows the two of them were
together it's a pretty cool is a pretty
cool little thing and it really kind of
like adds on to the existing nature of
poison ivy right we always kind of knew
to a degree there was an aspect of
immortality that we just didn't really
know how far it went of course this is
when it switches over to Wally West and
this is kind of a cool thing because you
sort of have like that woman you have
Harley you have poison ivy
Brewster Gould and Ted Kord we're just
sort of watching these two Wally West's
you know encounter one another and it's
because Wally West feels totally alone
and this is when the huge explanation
comes this is what it's all basically
revealed that what we find out here is
that when Wally
to piece together all these little bits
of information right like these little
tidbits of confessions and so on when he
experienced like this huge influx of
like pain and suffering from all these
heroes he cracked and of course we know
that led to him just kind of letting off
the Speed Force power and killing
everybody in the vicinity that part had
already been explained what comes next
is this idea that in Wally's mind
because he had killed all these people
what he needed to do was something that
would basically right the wrong he
needed an equally good thing to match
the equally bad thing and so what he
ended up doing was running five days
into the future grabbing himself and
then killing himself bringing it back
and then dropping it off and of course
as we know that would spear him five
days but the logic behind his actions is
what we didn't entirely know his initial
indication was wall just run back in
time and stop myself from blowing up but
as he points out with very Allen and the
flashpoint event we don't know what
ramification that would cause right I
mean for Barry it was keeping his mom
alive right like it was saving the life
of his mom and that changed the entire
universe something that's small that
seemed its remote for the most part to
be confined strictly to Barry right like
it wasn't like he saved Krypton from
blowing up and he saved Batman's parents
Neel and he prevented Joker from being
thrown into like the the VAT of
chemicals at ace chemicals lat and he
stopped to fasion being splashed with
acid its lucky he did all those things
right it's just he saved his mom's life
and that fundamentally altered the
entirety of the universe now Doomsday
Clock is kind of hitting on that in sync
well it really may have been more
Manhattan didn't like Barry Allen but at
the end of the day the actions of Barry
fundamentally changed the way the
universe was organized and structured
and what wally was doing as he was
looking at that and saying okay all
Barry did was save his mom's life now
we're talking about me going back in
time and preventing the deaths of a
whole bunch of heroes we have no idea
what impact that would have on the
universe so we said okay that's done
then the question became okay then what
good can I do in order to fix this and
that's why he basically compiled all
that information all the confessions
release it to Lois Lane and then had her
dump it to the press it forced the hand
of Superman is because what it did is a
force Superman to come out is like the
world's premier hero right like the one
hero everybody looks up to you and the
one hero that pretty much everyone
trusts came out and said guys what you
seen is real it's not a dupe it's not a
trick it's not some CGI Adobe After
Effects it's us as heroes confessing our
darkest moments the things that we
regret the most of mistakes we've made
and basically saying like we're humans
we screw up we feel pain and all that
kind of stuff we don't show you because
you have to look up to us and what are
we if we're emotional if we feel pain
and we feel suffering and we
want to give up sometimes and we do bad
things if we're not the people you've
built us up to be then we're nothing
we're nothing different than you and if
you can't rely on us to save the world
then you have to rely on yourselves to
save the world which can lead to
absolute anarchy because then suddenly
everybody becomes a vigilante you need
us to be heroes and you need to see us
as heroes therefore we could not let you
see us as anything but that that's why
we had sanctuary that's why we kept
everything hidden from but Superman
going out stepping out and revealing all
that basically meant that like the world
sees heroes as people as it was kind of
a fun thing kind of an interesting thing
because what this does is it it's halves
into wall-e and it really kind of
changes the entire dynamic of like
heroes in crisis because now it's no
longer heroes in crisis now it's the
crisis of Wally West right like I was I
was a Denver Comic Con this past weekend
and I was talking to Sal and he and I
were running over like what we thought
about heroes in crisis and he made that
good point he's like it's the crisis of
Wally West because when you look at
Wally as a character that's why is so
cool when you look at Wally as a
character all he's known since the
events of rebirth is lost right like
that that's all he's known before the
events of Flashpoint before the events
of rebirth that Wally West had Jai and
eyars he had his kids he had Linda he
had his family he had everything that he
ever wanted right I mean in a lot of
ways he lived the perfect life that was
the cool thing about Wally and that's
why so many fans loved him so much right
like crisis on Infinite Earths happens
Barry Allen basically dies or at least
was supposed to have died ends up
joining the Speed Force and he's gone
for the next 20 years
this sets the stage for Wally to
basically become the new flash and he
spends the first little bit of it under
the shadow of Barry and then finally
steps out of that shadow and says I can
be my own hero then he starts doing
things like tapping into the Speed Force
he starts doing things like mainlining
the Speed Force he starts becoming the
fastest of all the speedsters he starts
developing a new set of powers that not
even Barry had and then it comes up
where he basically marries the reporter
Linda Park did he has joy then he has
iris there was a point in time right
before the events of Flashpoint when
Wally had it all he had everything he
ever needed he had friends he had family
the whole nine yards and then flashpoint
happens and it's all gone
in the blink of an eye everything he
knows is is gone he encounters documen
Hatton we know that from the events of
Doomsday Clock he tries to stop dr.
Manhattan Manhattan
pushes him back into the Speed Force and
while he's stuck back there again
eventually he makes his way out when
Barry finally realizes who he is only to
come back to the real world and realize
the only people who seem to recall him
are Wally maybe a couple of the heroes
and like the Titans and
it but the people who mean the most to
him his children he doesn't know where
they are his wife doesn't know who he is
he's lost everything and so in this
moment when he basically goes to like
confess the things he's struggling with
when he can find a brief moment of
reprieve he kills everyone with a speed
force powers it's like well he can't do
anything but screw up right like ever
since the official events of Flashpoint
he's just out of sync with the way
things are supposed to be that he can't
do anything right and that's the
struggle of Wally West is he went from
being the hero to a guy who can't do
anything right and that's what's so
crushing is because ultimately he feels
totally alone and so in this moment
they're kind of stuck in a recursive
time loop right because the question is
if this all kind of repeats the same way
right like Wally runs into the pad or
runs through the future five days he
grabs that future version of himself he
brings it back you know kills him drops
the body off and then everybody thinks
that while he's dead and that buys in
the five days in order to bring together
all the confessions and then give it to
Lois Lane whodunit to the press and
Superman has to talk if it always plays
out that way then how do you break that
loop now this is where Tom King kind of
just I wouldn't say screws the pooch but
certainly takes the story in the
direction where it seems to kind of take
away from the impact of everything
because then what you end up having is
boosters all new charms up and says hey
just run to the future and just get a
cone of yourself and like kill the clone
bring it back drop the body off and then
you're fine you don't have to kill
yourself five days in the future and so
like that's it it's such an easy way out
to be honest it's such an easy way out
but that's kind of the funny thing is
because if you look at heroes in crisis
as a traditional superhero story then
yes that ending sucks and it ruins the
whole thing but if you look at it for
what it's supposed to be which is a
deconstruction of Wally West it's not
about the steps that while he takes in
order to to win the day it's about
what's going on with Wally how does he
view the world if you look at it through
those eyes the entire nature of the
story changes and I think that's where a
lot of people struggled I think a lot of
people kind of went into this because DC
built it that way so you really can't
fault them for it but a lot of people
went into this like it's a great big
huge event and it's a it's a huge story
and like all kinds of crazy things are
gonna happen DC didn't really build it
as a deconstruction of Wally
DC built it build it as like this is the
next big event you know and it's like
okay and then you get into and you
realize this doesn't quite work the way
it's supposed to now the thing about
this this is kind of the cool moment the
thing about this is that Wally kind of
sits down and says okay so I've done
this right like I went to the Future I
grabbed a clone I dropped it off I
killed him and that's the body they
discover done and done the recursive
time loop disclosed things can move
forward
there's still the question of what
happens to wall-e what goes on now
because while they kill people and then
he lied about it the frame boosts our
golden Harley Quinn and then he forced
Superman's hand to dump a bunch of
information that really probably
shouldn't been dumped in the first place
you know so what we're talking about
here is a guy who engaged in murder and
espionage so like what do you do with a
guy like that well of course
Wally ends up being taken to prison and
just kind of dropped off in a Cell now
it's sort of left open-ended by it by
Tom King and the sense of like Wally's
there but we don't really know what
comes next
I imagine that question will be answered
in Joshua Williamson's flash right like
Joshua waves will probably pick up from
that and and go from there either that
or Williamson will ignore it in its
entirety and it'll be like heroes and
crisis never happened and that'll just
be the end of it I don't know how you
treat the story like it never happened
if it was confined strictly to Wally and
he basically managed to open the time
loop and close it and no one knew about
it then sure you could just kind of
shoot this under the rug and say here's
a crisis never happened at all you're
talking about and call it a day but like
the confessions of the superheroes being
blasted out to the world you can't
really sweep that under the rug there's
no real areal like coming back from that
but at the end of the day again heroes
in crisis you know like I said if you
look at it for what it is right like the
way it was designed to be viewed then
it's a beautifully done story but the
issue is that a lot of folks are kind of
let in under the belief that it was a
big crisis crossover kind of Grand
Poobah event and and that was it so I
don't know I mean I'm I'm curious what
do you guys think I'm curious what your
opinions are because I'm sure they're
gonna vary I'm sure they're gonna be
people who are gonna be like here is a
crisis sucked and they're gonna be
people who are like heroes a crisis was
amazing so I'm curious what your all's
response is what you're all sought is I
enjoyed it but again I think the ending
kind of took away from what could have
been a great story even with it being a
deconstruction of wall-e but nonetheless
let me do you guys think if you are new
here to come this explain it make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video then make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]